in this video I'm going to cover random
numbers and the parse int function
create a random number between 0 & 1
with math.random now this will create a
number between 0 inclusive and 1
exclusive meaning it could be 0 but it
could never be 1 so if you look in the
console this is the random number that
we got and if you run every time I run
that you get a different number now if
you want to make sure it's a whole
number up to a certain number you can
multiply it by 20 or or any number and
then you can round it down so I'm going
to do math dot floor and inside math dot
floor we're going to do math dot random
times 20 I'm just going to put another
parentheses there and we got seven now
math that floormat random times 20 is
going to give us a number between 0 and
19 because remember it's always rounding
down so we could round down to 0 but
you're never going to quite get 20 so
it's not gonna I can't
round it down to 20 it will always round
down to 19 so this is between 0 and 19
if you want to generate a random number
that falls between two specific numbers
and that doesn't necessarily start with
0 you can use a specific formula let me
show you a function that uses the
formula okay so here's the random range
function we're going to pass in a min
we're going to pass in a Max and then
we're going to return this this is the
formula here that we're going to use it
starts off the same as what we had up
here we have math dot floor math dot
random and I'm going to multiply by this
thing we're going to multiply by max -
min plus 1 and then this to this whole
part right here we're just going to add
the minimum so right here I'm calling
the random range function I'm passing in
1 and 9 so this should give us a number
between 1 and 9 a random number between
1 and 9 so there's 4 every time I run
it's going to be another 1 6 and you can
see it's never going to give us a number
outside of that rain
okay the next thing I want to talk about
is the parse int function that just
takes a string and converts it to a
number as long as the string can be
converted to a number so if I do percent
and I pass in this string zero zero
seven or double-oh-seven
it's going to convert it to just the
number seven just going to run that and
you can see at the very end here seven
it's taking off the leading zeros and
just converting it to a seven if the
first character cannot be converted to a
string like t let's see what happens
there it's going to give us n a n not a
number so this can be especially helpful
when you're getting numbers from a pis
or JSON that end up being a string you
can convert them to a number now you can
also pass in a second argument which
would be the base of the number in the
string so if I have 11 here but then I
pass in the argument to we're going to
convert this from base 2 to an integer
that's in base 10 so I run that and you
can see 3 because 1 1 in binary
that's base 2 would equal 3 well thanks
for watching my name is Bo Carnes don't
forget to subscribe and remember use
your code for good